Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here with some things you can do
online now, guys.
Let's start the DONGs off in the right hands
with misternicehands.com.
You can pull his finger.
Wordle.net
analyzes text, like on a web site,
and generates a free
word cloud with fun sizes correlating to
the frequency with which the words
are used. Pretty awesome, right?
But is it the most
awesomest thing ever dot com ?
The site pits two things against each
other and lets you vote on which of the
two things
is awesome.
For instance, pilgrims versus Andrew Jackson.
I'm gonna have to go with pilgrims.
But periodic table
or Orson Welles? Which is awesomer?
Okay, it's tough, but I'm gonna have to go with
Mendeleev.
Now, the site tabulates everyone's answers
and runs a list
of what people currently consider to be
the most awesome.
Notice that right now, life is being beat
by the Internet.
Got a song stuck in your head?
Go to unhearit.com, a site dedicated to playing
equally catchy songs,
with the hope of removing the one
that's stuck in your head.
And if you like what you hear, check out
TuneGlue. Type in a band to add them to
the field and then expand them
to see other bands related.
Now, I also like Music-Map,
where you can enter a musician's name
and other bands orbit them at distances
related to how similar their styles are.
If you're tired of music recognition
programs that don't allow you to sing
your own song or
hum, enter midomi.com.
It's still not perfect,
but I am terrible and Midomi still
understood what I was trying to do.
"I won't loose a baby,
so why don't you kill me?"
Amazing.
Another flawless performance by Michael Stevens.
ThunderShark78 introduced me to Fracuum,
a series of mazes you continually shrink down
into.
The perspective is pretty cool.
Now let's get mathematical with Conway's
Game of Life. This one's a doozy, but
it's really famous. Right now I'm playing
it as a downloadable version for PC, Mac or Linux,
known as "Golly."
So, the game itself
is simply a grid that I can fill in and whether a cell
is alive or dead determines what the next
generation will look like.
What made this game so famous
is that using just a few deterministic
rules, we're able to create some quite
complex
things.
Now classically, the rules are very
simple. The fate of a cell depends on the
status of its 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 neighbors.
If two or three cells surround it,
it's gonna be fine, it's going to
continue to live. But if fewer than two,
or if more than three exist around it,
it will die of isolation or
overcrowding.
Now, likewise, if
a dead empty cell has 3, exactly three neighbors,
it will come to life.
So the next generation of this shape
looks like this.
It's amazing how just a few
simple deterministic rules can allow you to create
shapes like this one, known as a glider, which
across successive generations actually locomotes.
Oh, and GMSlash showed me a version where the cells
are mushrooms, and the longer a cell
lives, the bigger the mushroom gets.
But what's a game of life without love?
Themediabuffs sent me pretentious game,
a wonderful interactive poem that's
touching, but aware of itself.
And Connor showed me an even more tragic love,
a game where you play a guy in love
with a zombie.
Get her to follow you,
but keep her in a cage.
Also cute is Night
of the Loving Dead. You play a skeleton who
must find his body parts to reunite
with his true love.
As you acquire organs, like your brain,
you can begin to use new powers.
Now, if you're not
in love with a zombie and would prefer
to prepare for their attack,
TheArzonite offers you Map of the Dead,
a global Google Map delineating areas
where zombie activity will likely be
highest
in the event of an outbreak. It includes
helpful landmarks, like nearby food and
ammunition shops,
so you can plan your strategy now.
If this is all a bit too scary for you,
relax with N3xTB0y's
z0r.de, a collection of quick looping images
and silly music. Shantuku discovered this neat interactive scale of the universe tool.
We've covered things like this before,
but you can never have enough.
While we're out in space,
let's get bigger plane cosmic crush,
like Amonfobious'. Collide with smaller
items to grow larger and avoid
giant dangerous celestial objects.
Here on YouTube, Vixolent uploaded
a really well-made interactive
game. You play within a single video and
his use of annotations is quite
ingenious.
And TheRealMcJoni made this impressive interactive
domino video.
The tricks and layout are really neat
and you get to choose a direction at the
end of the video - let's hope it's the
right one.
Back to Metronomy.
Subscribe to Vsauce for more.
And as always,
thanks for watching.